so there's another company called rescue
time i don't know if you know about that
rescue time yeah it um looks at how you
spent your time and helps you figure out
how to rescue some of it back right so
that you're not
wasting time uh we're having an off-site
meeting for my group in google
there's about 100 of us and one of the
exercises i'm going to ask them to do is
look at your calendar for the past four
weeks
and put into buckets how you spent your
time
and you're going to be shocked at the
way that you spent your time
right
so analytics on how you spent the time
and maybe take a look at rescue time and
see what they do but i don't even know i
just know about the company and i know
generally that they analyze your time
and try to retrieve some of it
do you know if it's self-reported in the
sense that yeah it is okay yeah
yeah
so
that's another interesting
and also what's interesting is so we're
talking about the individual right how
can they better manage their time but
then you can also bring it to the
enterprise level and and so seeing not
necessarily like big brother-ish you
know he's not booking enough meeting
versus this guy but more as a company
here's how your team how your employees
are spending their time here's how much
they're traveling here's where they're
going here's how much you could be
saving by doing these little tweaks and
you know putting these regulations or
whatever here are the restaurants where
people are going and maybe you can cut
deals with these restaurants and so on
so there's ways that we can leverage
also for enterprises
analytics
so that they can optimize
the time of their teammates and also on
revenue and on cost as well yeah
so we see that also as part of our
enterprise play as we're getting into
companies it's spreading pretty rapidly
we're going to give analytics to the
individual users
but at the same point we can also give
analytics to corporations right
yeah that's a good idea
i think analytics is critically
important another company
sixth sense analytics
uh sixth sense analytics it got acquired
so it's not called that anymore but
basically what they did was they put a
agent on your desktop
and it kept track of every application
that you used and how much time you
spent in each application
and uh then it did this report uh to
tell you this is where you spent your
time
which applications and how much time and
it also aggregated it up and showed
across all the members of your group
it was kind of big brother kind of like
i don't know if i like this but it was
actually pretty interesting too much
time on twitter not enough time on my
corporate mail yeah right and then you
can compare yourself to others in the
group to see you know how you're seeing
and then overall the company you know
how team time was being spent
that could be beyond the bounds of what
you're
what you're doing but it's just another
way to think about you know
analyzing time
well analytics i think is the near term
thing that everyone
could use and it's not that hard to do
but no one has done it that's right
so i think zodney really opened my eyes
on
that part of analytics of email because
again you're in email every single day
and you're on top of it and you're
responsive and you think you know but
until you see those analytics and you
say oh my god i didn't realize that
these five people are the you know 80 of
my time
of who i'm sending email to i think if
you did the same thing to a calendar to
know where you're spending your time
yeah uh that would be huge absolutely
and if there are you know i'm not that
into this stuff but like um
uh who is it
franklin
is the calendar franklin planner
franklin planner yeah they have some
interesting kinds of
of
uh ways of
analyzing what you do and thinking about
what you do and there's another
what is this metrics thing about uh
there's some metrics thing about getting
stuff done
i don't know what it is but anyway it's
an entirely separate thing but if you
took those concepts and applied those to
analyzing your calendar
you know eye-opening kinds of things of
all the things we've talked about the
thing that excites me the most is
analytics on how
i've spent my time
and then maybe goal setting about how i
want to spend my time in the future
and the calendar sort of
sets these goals about hey you said you
wanted to spend 20 of your time on this
so slot it in there and you know then
or maybe it kind of graphs out
how
you'd like to spend your time
and maybe it's color coded or something
i don't know right and then you start
inputting
specific
uh meetings and schedules and and then
you see if you're meeting your goal or
not
so yeah analytics should be number one
absolutely um and then prospective going
forward how you manage your time you
know that would be great yeah overall i
think you guys are really smart to do
this because there are other scheduling
companies out there and yeah i think you
said the checklist is all about the same
yeah this really differentiates you and
puts you in a thought leadership
position and
then
just because you're a thought leader and
the visionary you're going to get more
than your share of the business
even though features might be the same
right so that's it's great it's good
idea